[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome, everyone.
We are very pleased
to have you here
for the Talks at Google series.
Our topic today is Meditation
for Rewilding the Self
by Nirali Shah.
Nirali, we are very
honored to have you here.
Thank you for being with us.
Just a little bit of
background on Nirali.
Nirali Shah is an artist,
writer, social worker,
and a meditation teacher.
She teaches
mindfulness meditation
with an emphasis on mind-body
awareness and self-inquiry.
She has spent thousands of hours
meditating in silent retreats.
She's a certified
mindfulness facilitator
from UCLA's Mindfulness
Awareness Research Center.
She lives in the Bay Area
and currently teaches
at nonprofits,
technology companies,
academic institutions,
and spiritual communities
such as Spirit Rock and
Insight Meditation Center
in Redwood City.
In the past, she
has served in one
of the largest slum
communities of Asia
for more than four years.
And she is the founder of
Shvaas, a nonprofit platform
that has helped streamline
thousands of hours of volunteer
efforts to work on meaningful
social change projects.
Assuming that a lot
of you are already
familiar with meditation,
and many of you
have learned basic mindfulness
meditation practices,
the talk today will touch
into some advanced aspects
of this practice.
Just like me, I'm
sure you too are
very curious to know
what re-wilding means
and what it has to
do with meditation.
So please join me in
welcoming Nirali Shah.
[APPLAUSE]
NIRALI SHAH: Thank you
all for being here.
It is such a delight
to be together building
community in this way.
I want to especially thank
Soneli for all her efforts
and her care in making
this event so beautiful
and smooth for all of us.
And I want to thank Google
for creating this space
to have conversations
such as these
in a very corporate setting.
And I really appreciate
that this kind of work
is coming more and more
into our mainstream lives.
Also, I want to have a round
of applause for Google, lots
of Google employees
who have been very
active in the protests
that are going on
and are showing up at airports
and at large protests.
And yeah, I want to
really cheer that.
[APPLAUSE]
So I want to talk today about
re-wilding, about emotions.
And in order to do that, I
want to take you back in time,
into deep time, about 15 years
ago in the life of Nirali
when she was driving a white
Mazda on the freeway of Los
Angeles, going to work, driving
an hour each way, going to work
to Malibu.
I was working in advertising
and design at that point
and following the
roadmap, following
the checklist, the
blueprint of what
it means to have a good life.
What am I supposed to do?
I'm supposed to
get a good degree.
I'm supposed to get a good
job, make some good money.
I'm supposed to have a
boyfriend or a partner
or a girlfriend, something.
And I'm supposed to--
yeah, I'm supposed to buy
a house, get a mortgage,
go for some exotic
vacations, get a car.
And somewhere, I
think I was made
to believe that that very next
achievement or acquisition is
what would fulfill me and that
would give meaning to my life--
the next car or the next job
opportunity or the next title
or award.
And that was perfectly fine.
And I felt like I was
living a good life.
I was doing pretty
well in that sense.
But internally, I
vividly remember
something feeling really out
balance, like off kilter.
And I started wondering what
was really going on for me.
And it was very hard to even
ask those kind of questions
because the minute I start
asking those kind of questions,
that starts creating some
disruption in my flow of life.
And so here I am trying to
ask those questions, and at
the same time,
distracting myself
in a lot of work and things
to do and a busy schedule.
And now when I look
back at that Nirali,
I can see that she
was struggling.
She was really struggling.
There was this kind
of a nervous energy
that she was trying to hide.
There was this low level
radio frequency of anxiety
or static pretty
much all the time.
There was the sense
of not feeling
completely safe and at ease in
my own skin, in my own body.
And that was painful.
There's this quote by
the writer Anne Lamott.
She says, "My mind is
like a bad neighborhood.
And I try not to
go there alone."
And that's kind of what
was going on there for me.
And there was also this sense
of being lost and unsure,
like this sense of
walking on eggshells
and not being fully sure of
what am I doing with my life.
Or is there even a
meaning or a purpose?
And at some point,
I found meditation.
And I started practicing.
And in the practice of
meditation, the promise was--
at least as I assumed it--
that it would reduce stress.
It would reduce my anxiety.
It would make me feel more in
control of what's going on.
And I was reading hundreds
of hours of scriptures,
Buddhist scriptures, or I
was reading Hindu scriptures.
Or I would look into Sufism
or Tao or J. Krishnamurti.
And I did a lot of retreats.
So now, instead of
frequenting nightclubs,
I was frequenting a lot
of meditation centers.
And I did dozens and
dozens of retreats.
And a lot of these
retreats when I started off
was in the SN Goenka
tradition, which a lot of you,
I think a few of you here
have done those, which
is these 10-day
retreats where you're
sitting for at least 10 hours
in cross-legged, in silence.
And your last meal is
at 11:00 in the morning.
And you're silent
throughout the entire time.
And so I did a lot of those.
And I thought that as I
do that, I would feel less
of an intensity of emotions.
What happened was
kind of the opposite.
The more I meditated,
I started feeling more.
More stuff came up.
And there's more emotions
coming up, strong emotions.
And I was like, oh, my god, I'm
doing something really wrong
here.
Maybe I'm not getting
this practice right.
But I was like, you know what?
I'm going to keep meditating.
I'm going to sit like a warrior.
I'm going to let these
emotions pass through me.
And I'm going to
become like the Buddha.
The Buddha is like someone
who's unshakable, unmovable.
No matter what emotions,
whatever happens,
he's blissed out in these
exalted mental states.
And I think I had
some misunderstanding
because I don't know if I was
really thinking of a Buddha
or a piece of furniture because
even a piece of furniture
is kind of unmovable
around emotions.
But that was my sense
that I'm going to keep--
and maybe I need to work hard.
Maybe I'm not performing enough.
And so maybe I need to
meditate more harder.
And so I did that.
And what happened in this
journey of the last 10 or 15
years is that what has happened
has kind of surprised me.
And what I want to do today
is share some of the insights,
some of these turnings,
that have come in my life
and how they have shaped me.
And also, I think they have
also clarified something very
beautiful and important for me.
And these are things
that I have not
heard enough around meditation
in our popular meditation
circles.
And so it feels
important to share these
because for me, these have
been ways in which I show up
to my practice and why
this practice feels
more immediate and honest
in my own experience.
So I want to share my first
learning or insight with you.
And that is around emotions.
I thought that the
more I meditate,
I will get rid of emotions,
of strong emotions.
But what has happened is that
I feel ever more connected
to my emotional world.
I remember going to a lot of
retreats back in India, as well
as here.
One of those retreats
was at this ashram,
where you go into a room.
And they actually lock
you from the outside.
There's a door.
There's a room with
an attached bathroom.
And I was meditating there
for about eight days.
And there's a small window.
And they push in food through
that window a couple times
a day.
And it was one of the most
beautiful and important
retreats of my life.
There is no windows.
There isn't even a fan.
It gets really bare.
And all you can do
is sit and go inside.
And I remember all
these strong emotions
of fear coming up there.
And it's so fascinating
to me because there
was no external
situations around fear.
And I could see how
these emotions are deep
already sitting in my body.
It's not like they are new.
They have always been there.
This fear has always been there.
There was another retreat where
I experienced strong anger.
This was a one-month
meditation retreat
where you're supposed to
be in silence and sitting.
And in that one-month retreat,
the strong emotion of anger,
around the 12th or
13th day, showing up.
And what was amazing was
that instead of seeing anger
as a problem, that this is
not the state of a Buddha,
of a good meditator, I think
for me what was important
was to allow all of
that energy of anger
without feeling embroiled in it.
And there was this capacity
because the mindfulness,
the sati, was so
strong that one could
allow these strong emotions
to show up without feeling
destabilized or overwhelmed.
And what happens when you
really allow these emotions is
you start seeing that
actually, these emotions
are like messengers.
When I sat with that
anger for three or four
days, strong anger, I could
see that that anger had a very
visceral charge in my body.
And when you continue
experiencing it,
I could see that--
So there was a story
in all of that.
But somehow, at some point, the
story was not that important.
And the mind was not
spinning in the story.
But somehow, there was
more awareness in the body.
And when that anger
was arising, I
could feel the charge,
the energy of the anger.
And what's amazing is I could
see that beneath anger is
a passion for justice.
Anger has a different
quality than hate.
It's not cold.
It's kind of hot.
And at another retreat, I could
see comparing mind showing up.
And when you have comparing
mind and when you can really
allow that, instead of feeling
guilty or bad about yourself,
really allow, receive that
as a gift, as a message,
you start seeing.
For me, I could see wow,
beneath this comparing mind,
there's a whole bunch of
self-loathing, self-hate.
And how does that work?
So you start becoming
more and more curious.
You investigate with
a lot of kindness.
So instead of trying
to get rid of emotions,
I think in this practice
what I was learning was that
how can I meet these emotions
with an even greater intimacy
and compassion.
And when we do that,
that is this capacity
to bring all parts of
ourselves to the practice.
And to me, that's
a very powerful.
The other piece
that's also something
I keep noticing is that by going
to more and more meditation
retreats, and also this piece
around spending time in nature,
is that at some point,
my mind starts relaxing.
So instead of feeling
this headiness
around constantly
spinning parts,
it almost feels like
the strings in my brain
are not being stressed or
stretched or pulled that hard.
And there's a kind of
soothing relaxation
that starts happening.
And then I can feel like more
and more energy is moving down
into the heart area.
And my capacity to
feel is heightened.
And that's really such an
amazing gift when you are not
spinning in thoughts or
stories, and your capacity
to feel emotions increases.
And you get a much deeper
access to your emotional world.
And sometimes, in that process,
strong emotions show up,
like shame, like fear.
And in that process, the
other thing that I have seen
is how feelings are
marginalized in our communities.
Because the more
and more I meditate,
I can see that this
is not a solo journey.
This is also as much
a relational journey.
But the way we have built our
world, feelings and emotions,
our sensory experiences,
intuition, all of this
is greatly marginalized
and almost even irrelevant
for a lot of people.
And so I feel like how
do we create spaces where
this is actually at the center.
Because when you study
like ancient or indigenous
communities, for a lot of
these communities, feelings,
intuition, all of
these qualities
were genuinely at the
center of their cultures.
There's a quote that I
really like by Joanna Macy.
She says, "The refusal to
feel takes a heavy toll.
Not only is there
an impoverishment
of our emotional
and sensory life,
flowers are dimmer,
less fragrant.
Our love is ecstatic.
But the psychic numbing
also impedes our capacity
to process and respond
to information.
The energy expended in
pushing down despair
is diverted from
more creative uses,
depleting the resilience
and imagination needed
for fresh visions
and strategies."
That great Thai
master Ajahn Chah,
he says that your practice
has not even started
if you haven't cried yet.
And I could see
in these retreats,
crying happened quite a bit.
And sometimes it
happened from a lot
of space of gratitude
and appreciation,
and sometimes, just the
heart breaking, just
really being in the midst of the
ocean of suffering and knowing
that that also is real.
And I could also appreciate
the sacredness of tears
and how cleansing they are.
But in our everyday world, if
I do that at Google, I mean,
that would be pretty
much stigmatized.
So I wonder how can
we also create spaces
where we can bring more
spaciousness for that too.
So that was my first
insight around emotions.
The second learning
that I wanted to share
was around control,
control versus chaos.
So as I practiced
more, one thing
that showed up for me
that instead of gaining
greater control or
predictability in my life,
this practice moved me
closer to the center of chaos
and uncertainty.
And it taught me
how to be with it.
And that was very
radical because I
think we often feel like
oh, if I meditate more,
things will be more stable.
But that's not
really what happens.
But what does happen
is our capacity
to be with that instability
and that uncertainty greatly
increases.
And so we enjoy it.
We can receive that.
We don't always enjoy it,
but we can receive that.
As I started moving more and
more in the spiritual path,
a lot of concepts
started dropping away,
started scattering
like dust particles,
a lot of ideas that
I had built. And I
could see all the
different ways in which I
had built my life that
was not authentic,
that was not really coming from
this deeper longing inside me.
And I could see the
violence that we
do to ourselves when we are too
afraid to be who we really are.
There's this quote by Anais Nin.
And she says, "The
day came when the risk
to remain tight in a bud was
more painful than the risk it
took to blossom."
I'll repeat that.
"The day came when the risk
to remain tight in a bud
was more painful than the
risk it took to blossom."
After about six months into
this and these practices,
I went to India.
And a few months after
that, I moved to India.
And I was there for
six or seven years.
And out of that time,
for about 4 1/2 years,
I worked with four
different nonprofits.
And one of them was working
in a slum community.
John was there.
And Samir was there.
There are actually
a few friends here
who worked with me
in those communities.
And at one end, I was
in LA on my track,
the blueprint, the map.
And here I was in the
midst of this uncertainty,
working in this community.
And one of the
projects I was doing
was working with these women who
did rag picking for a living.
And a lot of my days would be
going with this large gunny
bag on my shoulders
and walking the streets
for about a few
kilometers every day
and picking up
paper and plastic,
and putting my hands in perhaps
the worst garbage sometimes
that I could imagine
because I was learning
about the lives of these women.
And I was working on livelihood,
health and nutrition,
and micro-financing for them.
And so it was really important
to experience their life
and learn from them.
And a lot of times, my work,
I would be taking these women
to the hospital for checkups.
And somehow, when
I look back, this
was completely not
making sense, even to me.
Like, what is it that
I am really doing?
It was very confusing because
even the work in the nonprofit
was so random and chaotic.
Even the organization
that I started,
everything was just
kind of happening.
One of the projects that I
used to do is every few weeks,
I would cook a meal
for about 120 people.
And I would pack these meals
in these leaf containers.
And I would invite my friends,
and we would go to the streets.
And we would offer these meals
to people who were homeless.
And we would hang out with them.
We would sit with them.
We would connect with them.
And sometimes, I
would find people
who were in extreme
physical conditions.
This one time, there
was this man who
I met at the railway station.
And he had been on the
floor, lying there,
for maybe four or five days.
And he was covered in
his own urine and dirt.
There were all these
flies all over him.
And it didn't feel right to
just leave a meal and go away.
And so I picked him up.
And we took him to a hospital.
And I was trying to take care
of him for about eight days.
And unfortunately,
he passed away.
He had a very extreme
form of tuberculosis.
But all I knew in
that moment was
that it was important for me
to hold his life as sacred.
And that was not logical.
That was not a part of my plan.
It wasn't-- and I could
not control his death.
But somehow, being a
part of those experiences
has deeply shaped my
meditation practice.
I cannot imagine how I could
be doing this practice without
going through those experiences
and realizing that my own
well-being is deeply tied
to the well-being of others.
There's this poem by
Kabir, who is a Sufi saint.
And he says that I
have locked my house,
and I have burned it down.
And I have walked to
the village square.
And I'm waiting for you.
If you too have the guts to
burn your house, come with me.
And that's a very
provocative poem.
He says "Scorch the house
to make a house arise, yogi.
Protect it, and it's gone.
I saw a miraculous sight, yogi--
a dead man eating up dying.
The promise of a new house built
on the ashes of the old one
is a taste of your
authentic self.
The promise of a new house built
on the ashes of the old one
is a taste of your
authentic self."
And one of my teachers
said that in one lifetime,
you probably have to burn down
your house at least a half
a dozen times.
And I think it's
metaphorical, of course.
But what he's saying
is that there's
something around having
the courage to look
into all these
concepts and ideas
that we have built that are
not serving us in a deeper way.
And how can live do more
immediately, more honestly,
with our immediate experience?
There's another poem.
It's a Japanese poem.
And they say, "The sky
now cracks and falls.
The Earth cleaves open.
In the heart of the fire
lies a hidden spring."
And this word "fire"
is really important
when we talk about re-wilding
the self because "in
the heart of the fire
lies a hidden spring."
This practice is not mechanical.
It's not about going
through the motions
of the breath or the body.
This practice is really
about this deep curiosity
investigation.
And it's about meeting
that fire inside you
and even getting
excited by that fire,
getting nourished by that fire.
My last learning is
that instead of becoming
calm, though silent,
well-behaved,
the practice of meditation
made me more expanded,
awakening a fierce love,
and to some extent,
even threatening the status quo.
The Buddha was a revolutionary.
His fight of awakening
was one of rebellion,
a subversive path, subversive
against greed, against hatred,
against delusion.
He thought that
we have to travel
against the norms of society,
against own self-centered
tendencies.
In his own language,
he called this
the path of patisothagami,
which literally
means "going against the stream,
going against the stream."
And in that sense, meditation
is an act of resistance.
It is an act of
uprooting ourselves
in some ways from the
collective culture.
Because when we
are too embroiled
in the collective culture
and not investigating,
we are taking on a lot of
ideas, assumptions, pressures,
of what we ought to be doing.
And I think in that
sense, it's really helpful
to go to these retreats
because then you
can have that spaciousness to
look at life at your own terms,
a very direct experience.
When I started meditating
over the years, for me,
I think my understanding
of the different systems
of oppressions is becoming
more and more clear.
I'm feeling more awake
to all the different ways
in which oppression works
internally and externally.
Mindfulness is often
thought as a means
to stress reduction,
which is very great
and helpful and important.
And I teach that too.
But I think for me, it's
also very important to ask,
what is causing us stress?
A lot of what's happening
in our world right now,
I would actually be
surprised if people are not
stressed and anxious.
I mean, that would
be unimaginable.
If the environmental
destruction,
the political
oppression, the racism--
a lot of things are going on.
And if we are not
feeling anxious,
that would be really surprising.
And as a meditation teacher,
if I am prescribing behaviors
for calming and conformity
without bringing
this piece of social justice,
then I feel in some sense
I am encouraging a
spiritual bypass.
Because I wonder what is then
the difference between me
and an inexperienced
psychiatrist
who's not doing a good job.
What's the difference between
the psychiatrist who's simply
pushing more and more
drugs and more and more
palliatives on his
client, but not
really asking or questioning
the roots of what
is making that client go
through a difficult time?
What is causing psychosis?
What is causing trauma?
And so as a result, I think
it's really important for us
to look into all the
different ways oppression is
taking place in our societies.
If the Buddha was alive
today, he would definitely
be doing a lot of
meditation and put
into a correctional facility--
[LAUGHING]
--because also what
we need to think about
is also what is normalcy.
And what is normalcy in a world
which we are living today,
which is essentially
an industrial growth,
capitalist society
that we are living in?
And so what is normalcy?
I mean, because a
lot of things that we
see as normal are
actually quite extreme,
the ways in which
competition works,
politics works.
It's really extreme.
And so I feel it's
really important
to bring this piece of
different oppressions
into our conversation and really
ask ourselves, what am I doing?
Other than meditation, what am
I really doing in the world,
and doing for myself and others?
I might be a part of this
system of oppression.
And so in that sense, meditation
is not a consumptive act.
I feel that instead of calming
down and almost numbing down,
this practice of meditation has
made me more fiercely engaged.
Instead of moving
into a retreat space,
it is moving me more and
more into a collective space.
And I feel that if more and more
people are meditating this way,
I think a lot of these systems
of hierarchy and oppression
would disrupt and
dismantle in no time.
Because meditation is not
an act of domestication.
It is not exaggerated
politeness or obedience.
Meditation is a subversive act.
It is a revolutionary act.
So I want to end with sharing
with you a few ways that
guide my life at this
point, after these 15 years.
I feel each one of
us is the custodian
of this wild and fierce love
for all of this existence.
And we are fluid
space-time beings
interwoven through the
strands of our breath
through the juices
of our joys and tears
and our shared longing to care
for and heal our beloved Earth.
Though we are conditioned to
act competitively, separate,
but at the same time,
if we can pierce
through that thin
membrane of delusion,
we expand into our
creative force,
into the vast
firmaments of wisdom,
into the stream of great
compassion within us.
This practice has brought
me more and more connected
to the Earth.
I feel that instead
of transcending,
I feel more embodied in the
here and now than I was before.
And also, I feel more
connected to the very core
of our powerful Earth.
And I also feel like
a lot of this practice
teaches me is that I am nature.
And as I meditate, I
am returning to nature
what already belongs to nature
and that I have misappropriated
as I. And so this deeper
interconnectedness,
interwoveness, with the Earth
is becoming more and more
real in my life.
I also have started noticing
all the different ways
in which this very wild,
primal energy inside us
was pushed down.
I mean, I feel I was very
domesticated, very shut down.
And this primal force inside
me was abandoned and ignored
and pushed away in some
corner of my psyche.
And this practice of meditation
is bringing that energy alive.
And that energy is
very deeply connected
to the energy of the Earth.
So meditation does not have
to be an anesthetic act.
It is ascetic act.
[LAUGHING]
And I think I want to
leave you at the end
of this talk with one question.
It's a line from the
poet Mary Oliver's poems.
A lot of what I read
today, a lot of poems,
are coming from some beautiful
women writers and teachers.
And when I was writing
this, I realized
that I'm somehow
tapping into the lineage
of these beautiful
women through history.
So the line is,
"Tell me what you
plan to do with your one
wild and precious life."
Thank you so much.
I appreciate you listening.
[APPLAUSE]
We have a few minutes.
So I'm happy if anyone
has any questions.
AUDIENCE: So you said
that you were following
this plan, [INAUDIBLE].
And even though there was
this radio frequency constant,
you would push that back.
What was it that motivated you?
Was it just a constant
thing, and you decided
that I need to do something?
Or was it something that
really shook you up,
and that you decided
to take up meditation?
NIRALI SHAH: Hmm.
From what I remember, it
was happening over time.
So it wasn't like
one snap, like one
day even I realized that, OK,
I'm going to change things.
But one thing that
I do realize is
that at some level inside me, I
was asking this question around
is there any meaning,
or is there anything
sacred about life.
Or was it just this mundane way
of living and getting things
done and getting a paycheck?
Is it all supposed to be
kind of flat like that?
And I personally
feel that there's
nothing more sad than
seeing life as meaningless
or not sacred.
That would be a huge loss.
And that didn't feel like
a way I wanted to live.
And so I wanted to discover
if there is something.
AUDIENCE: I think the
way you describe it,
I think I'm probably living a
really sad life because there
are times when I
ask these questions.
And there's also, I think--
at least I feel-- that there's
a pull that pulls you back.
There is some excitement
about the mundane things
that we are doing.
But then why are you doing them?
You're enjoying them.
But when you come back,
you realize oh, what
was the point of it all?
And so I was curious
because for me,
it's a constant back and forth.
Maybe I'm miserable both places.
And maybe I'm enjoying
both the places.
So I was curious
that gradually, you
were able to go
further into meditation
and actually explore more.
NIRALI SHAH: Yeah, and even
the mundane things, actually, I
can feel over the years,
they're becoming more radiant.
They're shining with-- like the
simple act of making coffee,
it feels like there's
something radiant and sacred
about that, and this act of
just watering the plants.
And so there is some kind
of a deeper connection
or emotional connection
to mundane things.
AUDIENCE: So meditation is--
all these things you talked
about are very positive things.
But I've heard of
a lot of stories
about people who go
to these retreats,
and myself included, who have
a really hard time with it.
And you don't often
hear about this.
And so when that happened
to me, I was very surprised.
And I was like,
what did I do wrong?
Why am I having a hard time?
And I'm wondering, have
you ever experienced
something like that?
NIRALI SHAH: Oh,
yeah, I can deeply
resonate with some of
what you are saying.
I don't know which
retreat you went to.
But I can definitely
tell you that it is
a very, very skillful process.
It's a very skillful practice.
And over time, I
have seen that there
are times when I have driven
myself a bit too hard.
And it has taken me some time
to recover and heal that.
So absolutely.
I think it really helps to have
a very skilled teacher, a very
experienced teacher, who you
can check in with very deeply
and who can understand you
very quickly also because there
isn't sometimes a lot of times
at these retreats to talk.
But for me, it's also been--
if I could share one thing--
that as I meditated,
I started experiencing
some very beautiful
states of great beauty,
I mean, great expansion, a
great sense of connectedness,
of feeling really connected
to something much vaster.
And a lot of times,
I would actually not
tell my teachers of this because
sometimes, some teachers, they
are not skilled, and
they don't have--
I mean, they can
reflect it back at you
in a way which might not
support you at that time.
So it's very
important to go slow.
And the last thing
also I can tell you
is that working with emotions
is not an easy practice.
And any time you
meditate, you are
going to face strong emotions.
And it's very important to
learn how you work with emotions
because if you go too much,
it can destabilize you.
And so there's a whole
somatic piece around this.
And you don't want to get
overwhelmed, because if you do,
your nervous system
will go into a flight,
fight, or freeze response.
And that can be hard.
So for me, a lot
of my practices,
like really practicing delight.
It's not all suffering
and hard work.
A lot of this
meditation practice
is learning to take in
great, great delight.
So much of the way we function,
when very difficult or painful
experiences come in, our
system is not ready to take it,
and we put it under the carpet.
And at the same time, when very,
very pleasurable experiences
come, we do the same thing.
We put great pleasure
under the carpet,
because the mind, the
ego, wants to stay
in this lukewarm,
neutral territory.
And it doesn't have the
capacity to take in.
And so over time, you start
building a greater capacity
to work with these emotions.
I don't know.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
When you do overdo it, how
do you balance it back?
What's the best way
to balance yourself?
NIRALI SHAH: So I can
give you an example.
I was at a retreat.
And some deep
stuff, trauma stuff
came up for me from 15
years ago or something,
like really old stuff.
And it was hard.
And what I did is I
stopped meditating.
I got up.
I went to my room.
I took a nice shower.
I wore some nice clothes.
I went for a beautiful walk.
I hung out with the deer.
I looked at the flowers.
I enjoyed a nice cup of tea,
really, really relaxing myself.
And then after a few hours,
I went back on the cushion.
And I had a lot more
capacity to be with that.
And then again, I
would see, OK, this
is getting too intense for me.
So now I'm going to take
in some more delight
because I don't want to
stretch my nervous system.
AUDIENCE: My question
is around meditation
as a personal practice
versus the rest of my life,
being connected to other
people like family and friends.
So how do you
reconcile the rewiring
that's happening and you're
redefining your sense of self
and your priorities and
having all these paradigm
shifts with those that are
close to you who are not
on this journey
with you if you're
doing it as a personal thing?
Have you had
experiences where you
had to reconcile with
that in certain ways?
How do you bring your
loved ones along with you
on the journey or whatever?
NIRALI SHAH: I can just
say to my own experience
is that at some point,
it was not easy.
At some point, at
the time, my parents
could not understand what
I'm doing with my life.
And I feel like I had to just
go through that, at least
in my case, because I knew.
I had a sense of
what I was doing.
It was not completely
clear at the time,
but there was still
a deep calling.
And I knew that I had
to be true to that.
And yeah, it was kind
of rocky at that time.
And now, all these
years later, they
have deep respect and
love and gratitude for me
and for the path I have chosen.
And they are
incredibly supportive.
So I wish I could have taken
them with me at that time.
But that was not happening.
And I saw that also as
a part of my practice,
that how this is
shaping my truth
or my faith in this practice.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
You mentioned meditation
is a revolution.
Do you think there is
a way to get people
to be part of the revolution?
Or do you feel like we
should try to get people?
NIRALI SHAH: [LAUGHS] We should?
How do you mean that?
AUDIENCE: So should
we try to get people
to be part of the revolution?
Or should we let them be?
If they want to be
part of the revolution,
should we try to get them to?
So it's like should you
convince people to meditate,
to do like--
NIRALI SHAH: It's actually
a very meaningful question,
what are you asking.
I can see the subtlety
in what you're asking.
Because obviously,
you're not seeing
that we should try to
force people to meditate.
I know you're not asking that.
So there's a nuance
to your question.
I feel that there are two
ways in which meditation
seems to be happening.
One is that it is my stress, my
problems, my anxiety, my life,
and I need to get
rid of all this
so that I can live
a better life.
Maybe there's subconsciously
their ideas of I
could be higher or
superior or better
than others in the world.
And that could be one
frame of how people
are approaching meditation.
And I think for me as a
teacher, it's important to offer
the second frame of how this
practice works because I
genuinely feel that this
practice cannot go too far
if it's just about "my," if
it's consumptive in nature.
Because I feel that as we
practice more, these layers
or membranes of separation,
they start thinning out,
and we start experiencing
this powerful shared
humanity with each other.
And for me, in that sense, this
practice is deeply relational.
I offer retreats which are all
about relational mindfulness.
And those are ways in which
we start becoming very, very
supportive to each other.
So I think yeah, to
offer this other frame is
very important and meaningful.
And then, of course,
it's their choice.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So most of the
tech world in Silicon Valley
is going like AI.
And what you're talking
about is going--
more machine-like.
And there'll be machine
inside of me, outside of me.
And maybe I'll be a machine.
I don't know.
A lot of stuff
going on like that,
and that's the quote-unquote
"future" that people
are really proud of.
And you talked about going back
to the wild and nature and back
to the Earth.
How do you reconcile
those two things?
Because most of our society
is getting more and more
techno-enabled.
NIRALI SHAH: I cannot
reconcile the two personally.
And I say that standing
here at Google.
[LAUGHS]
I personally feel-- at
least that's my sense--
is that over time,
as we are becoming
more AI and more
machine oriented,
I feel that there will be
communities and people who
will make a choice.
And there would be some
who would move more
towards the Earth and
some who would move more
towards machines.
I don't think machines are bad.
I don't think technology is bad.
It can be very helpful.
I use a lot of technology.
And there is a lot to be said
around appropriate technology.
But I feel that technology
which can bring a lot of feeling
and emotion is very important.
So to answer your question, I
cannot fully reconcile the two
because I think the aspect
around feeling, energy,
emotion is very
real to my practice.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
for someone starting out
in meditation practice
how you would recommend
starting, if you weren't to
just drop your career and life
and move off to an ashram.
[LAUGHTER]
NIRALI SHAH: Yeah, I don't think
it's important to drop your--
I think it's completely,
perfectly possible
and great to--
maybe that's authentic
to your experience
right now is to have a stable
job, have a stable family.
And that stability can be very
helpful to the practice too.
So it's very personal.
How to start?
There are a few ways.
There's Insight Meditation
Center in Redwood City.
Gil Fronsdal is a
wonderful teacher.
So they have regular sits.
Monday nights is a
good place to start,
where there would be
sit and a Dharma talk.
And I think there is SIY
here, Search Inside Yourself,
at Google.
And they also offer
the introduction
to mindfulness
meditation practice.
And then if you
feel so inclined,
there are these ten-day
meditation retreats
by SN Goenka.
I personally recommend
Spirit Rock as well,
which is in Marin.
And they have a lot of retreats.
I would check out some
of those websites.
I want to really thank you for
your time and for being here.
And it's really
very special to be
able to sit together
in this context
and share our lives
with each other.
So thank you so much
for listening to me.
Take care.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you,
Nirali, for your talk.
And thank you
everyone for your time
and your beautiful questions.
If you feel stuck in
your meditation practice,
you can shoot an
email to Nirali.
You can contact her
at www.niralis.com.
It's N-I-R-A-L-I-S.com And
you can find her information
and contact information there.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]